le métier de secrétaire mairie est un
des métiers les plus essentiels au
fonctionnement de notre organisation
territoriale ils forment des binômes
avec les maires et font vivre notre
service public au quotidien sur les
territoires ils sont aujourd'hui 23000
agents travaillant dans 29600 communes
de moins de 3600 habitants et pourtant
ils sont aujourd'hui le métier le plus
en tension de la fonction publique
territoriale près de 30% d'entre eux
prendront leur retraite d'ici 2030 c'est
un défi de recrutement pour pour notre
pays et pour ce métier cela justifie des
mesures exceptionnelles et c'est ce
qu'on a voulu développer en proposant
dans notre rapport
d'information sénatoriale une
organisation et des propositions pour
rendre ce métier plus attractif cela
passe d'abord par un plan de formation
initiale formation professionnelle afin
d'intégrer des secrétaires de mairie au
rang de catégorie B ou de catégories A
alors qu'aujourd'hui 60% d'entre eux
sont classés en catégorie C qui
correspondent habituellement à des
tâches d'exécution deuxièmement c'est de
leur apporter une vraie reconnaissance
une reconnaissance qui passe à la fois
par un titre professionnel nous créons
le titre de secrétaire général de mairie
pour les agents de catégorie B ou a nous
reconnaissons aussi les responsabilités
qui sont les leurs en instaurant une
prime de responsabilité qui viendra
prendre en considération les
responsabilités qui sont les leurs dans
le dans les postes qu'elles exercent et
donc apporter une reconnaissance en
terme de rémunération mais aussi mieux
intégrer ces primes dans les calculs
pour la retraite troisièmement c'est de
leur offrir des perspectives de carrière
une filière métier faire en sorte que un
agent de catégorie C puisse passer en
catégorie B devenir secrétaire général
de mairie par la promotion interne en
reconnaissant l'expérience
professionnelle qui est la sienne ou en
validant une formation qui permet cette
promotion hors quota et hors concours
même chose pour les agents de catégorie
B qui doivent pouvoir avoir des
perspectives de passer l'échelon sup
quatrième axe c'est mieux mieux les
accompagner dans leur mission les
accompagner ça veut dire de la formation
continue ça veut dire les intégrer dans
des réseaux professionnels inexistants
aujourd'hui ça veut dire créer des
outils numériques ou des outils à leur
disposition pour leur facilité le
travail au quotidien c'est aussi par
exemple créer des référents à l'instar
du référent préfecture dédié à leur
mission afin que chacun et chacune
d'entre elles puissent avoir un
interlocuteur dans les services de
l'État qui fait très souvent défaut sur
les territoires dans lesquels elles
exercent enfin c'est faire aussi la
promotion de ce métier pour répondre aux
défis qui est le nôtre de recrutement de
près de 40% de de la profession d'ici
2030 c'est un enjeu majeur pour la
continuité de nos services publics pour
garantir et conserver des mères dans nos
dans nos territoires qui doivent pouvoir
s'appuyer sur des secrétaires de mairie
et des critères généraux de mairie
formés mais aussi pour l'ensemble de
notre pays